you're online officially act today you
haven't played any today though right
not today no you played a bunch of it
last week yeah I played like six hours
last week at Konami before we get into
what you thought of it back then I want
to talk a little bit about what happened
today when our boy had Josh Shaw who was
a currently running the show he can't
come out here and talk for himself their
parenting there's some crazy like host
migration problems happening where when
the host disconnected from an online
game it like straight off just kill the
game and that's like some 2008 like
online sure yeah I mean it's running
into some early problems that you might
expect from a more standard again the
the fact that this is kind of coming
much later in metal gears life is a
little bit weird that they didn't get
that sorted out a little bit beforehand
yeah I remember the trailers for was a
Call of Duty whatever Modern Warfare 2 I
think it was whatever like look host
migration there whatever that stuff
happens so yeah there might be that's
just to put a caveat on it there might
be some technical hitches happening
online with Metal Gear Online but in
terms of gameplay Mike what did you
think about your time playing it I
really enjoyed it it's it's like enough
of a game on its own a multiplayer
experience but it also takes the parts I
loved about single-player phantom pain
and kind of just injects it into this
competitive arena that's still very much
if you're playing a certain like certain
game modes like cloak and dagger which
is my favorites like elimination but the
attacking team can only use non-lethal
weapons Wow
yeah and then they get like permanent
octocamo
but if the other team shoots them or
like marks one of them then it'll reveal
them all for a few seconds but defending
team gets lethal weapons it's just this
cool dynamic and then there's a lot of
emergent stuff that comes out of a
single player like I'm sure you've seen
a ton and metal you'd like the phantom
yeah and the phantom pain just whenever
you're you know going into an outpost
it's just always random crap seems to
happen that you're like oh I wonder if I
can do this yeah then it works at and I
was hearing about you and the full term
recovery system yeah talk talk to us a
little bit about that so you can like
there's CQC and whatnot in multiplayer
as well you know you run up someone tap
r2 as you're moving to just like throw
them like onto their back or you can
hold it and then interrogate someone by
holding l1 and then if you fill up the
meter without someone else shooting you
which like good scouts good snipers will
stop you
you can reveal the entire enemy
the team won seconds late it'll mark
them on the map teammates and then if
you're playing bounty hunter and they're
these so this is comlink right here it's
kind of zones and the attacking team us
to fill up that meter you can Fulton
people and it just it it's just it's
counts for more points toward you but if
bounty hunter if you're playing bounty
hunter mode which has like these two
ticket pool like respawns you know you
know you deplete those by killing the
other team but if you actually Fulton
someone with a high bounty on their head
it'll return that bounty into your
response so if you don't kill them if
you actually like go to the effort of
presumably players on the team yeah like
stunning him then filtering them yeah so
say one of the other people gets 11
kills we'll say 11 over their head and
you're like the entire other team is
like let's protect that guy so they
don't get those 11 back and then right
here you can see that if you're fooling
someone you have to also kind of protect
them but stop that a team from shooting
the balloon in one particular instance
when I was playing last week it was
myself and one of the other guys and the
other team and we kept just stunning
each other and trying to fold each other
but both our teams are on opposite sides
shooting both our balloons today was
this endless loop of just like it's just
one going up and then dropping and then
stunning the other person and then that
person going up dropping and then
stunning so finally someone just lobbed
a grenade into the middle and we both
really but it was it's really fun I
liked it a lot there's a lot of absurd
stuff that happens just like in that
Metal Gear fashion though I was I was
trying to get this disc in cloak and
dagger the attacking team can extract
these disks to win and I was about to
bring it to the evac so and I turn a
corner and Konami's solution to like a
non-lethal mine is ad dog plushie okay
okay yeah I've seen this you guys sort
of transfixed by it right squat down
kind of do this like amused look this
really yet transfixed look with hearts
over your head and your because you see
on for like three seconds he's very cute
yeah I agree I don't know if I'd go in
like really inspect it during a battle
battle yeah yeah so that someone round
the corner and shot me in the back and
it was so stupid but in the best way and
I didn't mind at all like how this feels
like Metal Gear I guess and speaking of
things that are stupid and I hear
something in badges is it Eva from Metal
Gear Solid 3 explain this one to be
Justin here so you can get a tactical
advantage Eva of course has a
has an outfit that is sexy okay in the
Coogee movie nice slightly revealing or
are less revealing than quiet
nothings is really yeah but one of the
things that she can do is if you want to
get a little bit more maneuverability
you can unzip me you know it's tight
your uniform can be very tight and gets
more maneuverability by unzipping what
is wrong read a little bit more yeah
dude what did you play around as my love
Kojima but there's a certain part of his
brain is still like a 12 year old boy
like I've been trying to spend so much
money to get quiet some goddamn clothes
it cost so much research yeah I've got a
jumper quote tactical advantage unquote
oh my god well there you go
I see the sexism coming into Metal Gear
Online as well so I don't believe you're
actually playing as Eva but you it is
it's like a I'm assuming it's a female
I'm maybe the male characters can wear
it as well but it is an alpha or maybe
you can't because they actually there is
a bunch of like popular characters yeah
so I you can play a snake if you're on
Team snake yeah or you can also play as
Ocelot who he has this like the double
revolvers if someone near you is marked
you can ricochet bullets off that's cool
yeah they're pretty overpowered but you
can turn them off and then snake just
has really good CQC or the press that I
got I'm like can I just is most of the
like I know you and your paper like five
hours or so but it's most of like the
late game development stuff from Metal
Gear Solid 5 in this like is there like
rocket arms that like get blown out from
it's got its own progression system
entirely its own so there is a lot of
the same stuff of the d-dog plushie I
believe is specific to multiplayer but I
had didn't see any prosthetic arms aside
from snakes everything else you know you
can get to level 37 your first time
through and then you ascend it's kinda
like prestige look what next time there
you get to 38 and you get like a power
weapon and then you go back to the one
then go up to 39 the 40s the cap but you
kind of get a new level item every well
I like that it actually bumps up the
level each time your prestige actually
is pretty cool and so this is also
completely separate from the other
online mode for Metal Gear where you
have your base and you're building that
up and yeah the Forward Operating Base
tough god this game is just like I tell
him I've played maybe 80 hours so far
and like I was talking to Don a John
Baum about like where I am he was like
oh you've still got like 30 hours
where I am and talk to us a little bit
about the classes then as well there's
infiltrator Scout enforcer how do they
play differently the Scout is kind of
just you know a sniper or just longer
range they're kind of back from the
action and they also can you know you
you it's a big part of the game to like
mock mark people yes and the Scout you
can get perks that let you mark them
faster and you reveal them they I tried
sniping at first it was really tough
just because the you know there's that
bullet travel time in metal gear which
translates into multiplayer and the
action of the characters is very
frenetic yeah running a lot yeah it's
the same kind of movement that snake
doesn't phantom pain also there's the
other enforcers more of the tank you can
get like heavy armor riot shields no
cool machine guns if you want and then
the infiltrator which is my favorite you
can get you can equip camouflage and
also they're just faster um they also
work really well if you don't put as
many items in their inventory because I
think it weighed down Oh a big deal for
any for any class that was more
encumbrance yeah the more attachments
and the heavier weapons and the more
like armor you have it'll you'll get
winded fast wow that's cool yeah so Josh
this morning he would he sprinted for
like five seconds and stopped and you
can hear the character breathing he's
like what the hell is this like are you
and then if we look back it was probably
like a low rating at his but it's a
trade-off then you can just do that on
purpose if you're not gonna be doing too
much sprinting if you're a scout it
might not matter if you're gonna be kind
of camping out anyway but yeah each
character kind of lends a different you
know approach to playing which is really
cool it's cool that seems like there's
loads of like really interesting
differences in this that you don't get
in a lot of modern shooters or online
shooters like most you know we used to
play in Call of Duty every year or like
even gave us a guest thing which are
breaking out in in terms of other ways
like most multiplayer sort of team
multiplayer whatever it's still on the
same very familiar lines but between the
game modes and the type of technology
you use and even sort of stuff like that
just weird idiosyncrasies that exists
like encumbrance and her in a
multiplayer shooter it it sounds like it
feels like a very different type of
online shooter yeah it is and I was
actually pleasantly surprised
you know like Metal Gear has always been
more of a single-player experience to me
and I thought maybe this would be kind
of tacked on and it's very separate but
it's still very fun I like that there's
a lot of kind of
crazy scenarios I wasn't expecting like
a D dog plushie or just two people going
up and downs and why not
I'm not so many in five hours so who
knows what's gonna happen that'd attack
and fortunately even though this is the
last metal gear that cochem is working
on the next metal gear will still be a
single-player experience because we'll
be playing in a pachinko parlor doctor
your big boss has already been I didn't
big boss erotic pachinko machines right
badly if Konami yes all would come in
and he'll will unzip is uniform yeah
exactly
more comfortable for more better agility
you know yeah there you go yeah
what if what if they pan up and that is
just sneak talk too good all right I'm
back on board at that hour that's pretty
good no didn't work yeah they've got her
goggles and everything that's oh yes I
do to the original Ava outfit but guess
we'll find out pretty soon Metal Gear
Online ouch now technically everyone's
rushing to downloaded on PSN which takes
its goddamn time although also I'm a PC
of course and everyone else Xbox as well
just nobody in the office thing on Xbox
I just realized so anyone in the office
playing and these articles are used
stuff right now for other stuff yeah
and he's just doing it for for so I feel
probably people playing here no one's
banging on Xbox you play what your
friends are on and when all of our
friends are playing on PlayStation man
I'm paying to which your 3 on xbox one
and it's great I love my 29 frames a
second oh yeah on Xbox because DLC
doesn't transfer over I bought all of it
on me too I'm gonna see the same thing
and the instruments presumably as well
yeah maybe they don't thank you so much
Mike priority coming on talking telling
us all about Metal Gear Online very much
looking forward to playing it and let us
know if you are thanks very much for
watching today's show folks